spending time with your mom on Mother's
Day is a great way to show her how much
you care yeah but sadly when your mother
is no longer living you have to find
other ways to honor her and Sherry you
have an incredible story just such a
wonderful story about a young man who
found a great way to do just that well
you may have eaten at a local restaurant
here in the valley called lemongrass and
lime it was the vision of a motivated
career woman and mom who never got to
finish living out her dream now her son
honors her by carrying on in her
footsteps
my name is Toby malus I am the main
owner of lemongrass and lot cooking and
serving up delicious Thai food is in
Toby malice's DNA I like the survey has
a big fast you know it's fun play energy
okay you know it's flashy too it's
flashy too but for 21 year old malice
running an award-winning restaurant is
definitely not a flash in the pan when
did you know that this is what you
wanted to do
you know honestly just like spend time
with Mom here when working on her
it was so fun I like being around it but
I loved her obviously D malice was the
Visionary of lemongrass and lime a
native of Thailand she brought her
culinary creativity and ambition to
America to be successful in everything
she imagined she was a very driven
person and she was just always motivated
his mom's determined Spirit made its
mark on Toby when he and his twin
brother pan were in high school D had
beaten breast cancer and at the urging
of her own mother opened her first
lemongrass and Lime restaurant in 2018.
Toby shared her love of food every time
we go to a restaurant together
my mom would uh we'd order something we
like and we would just guess all the
seasonings in it and really get the most
yeah that's what we used to play a
little game with each other their love
of food games became a career calling
for Toby when Dee's cancer returned and
this time took her life Toby decided he
would carry on the dream his mom had
started you're going to help and then I
obviously the cow soy like curry paste
sugar and all those like good spices in
there this is the one dish also my mom
in particular showed me how to make
because it was one of her favorites I
taught you how to cook this this one
yeah this is my mom's favorite station
Curry's what was it that she liked about
this I think she just like loved how
everything came to the other and she
just loved the presentation of it too
from learning to master her best dishes
to delivering good old customer service
Toby trained with Dee as she prepared
him for the days and years ahead without
her standing by his side when she had
the cancer I think she like one thing I
like her she treated every single day
like it was a blessing and she would
just like hey I woke up today I'm gonna
grind the whole day Toby says he'll keep
working to earn the titles of Chef and
owner his mom passed on to him it just
feels right you feel like I just know
I'm going down the right path in life
well Toby is going to Thailand to visit
family later this summer and spend
several months immersing himself in the
culture culinary school learning more of
the language and he says he'd like to
eventually expand lemongrass and lime to
other states like Arizona Utah and
possibly California we sure do wish him
well